on the front lines near bakmud there's a
constant sound of shells flying overhead
trenches and bunkers are the only cover
out here
Ukrainian soldiers wait for their
reconnaissance drone teams to send them
details of Russian troops
but whenever they fire
Russian troops fire back
we wait inside until there's a lull in
the firing the ukrainians have told us
we can't show any roads landmarks or
anything that will reveal their
positions this Soldier says he was a
kitchen appliance salesman before
Russia's Invasion now they call him the
electrician
between us and Them is about 1 800
meters of open space and when someone
appears it is very noticeable there was
a time when Russians fired mortars
machine guns and also snipers sure they
answered them it all lasted not more
than an hour
life is simple on the front line no
mattresses here there's wood and a
blanket
this is a small almost family home
they're the beds where we sleep and
afterwards we swap we don't have Hotel
conditions where everyone has their own
place someone's working someone's on
duty and someone's resting here's my
colleague resting now
Ukrainian troops faced both Russian
soldiers and troops from the
self-declared donex People's Republic or
DPR
their tactics are using a lot of men to
push forward and are aggressive in this
they use Aviation and artillery the
Russians massively struck on exact
locations and the DPR quite randomly it
doesn't matter what they hit
he's been fighting on the front line
since 2014 when separatists took control
of parts of eastern Ukraine we need more
weapons I mean more Western weapons not
only guns but also High precision and
High Caliber weapons we give the
Russians a good punch but we would like
more Western weapons to raise our morale
we're told in the last few days the
Russians have been trying to push
forward
in some places along this Front Line the
Russians are less than two kilometers
away the men here say they've seen
intense fighting as Russian forces tried
to break through the Ukrainian front
lines
the soldier spots a movement
foreign Max points out to us that our
flak jackets are useless here go through
here yeah easy easy but on the
Battlefront they don't think about dying
all they want to do is hold the line
and make sure their country doesn't fall
I said Big Al Jazeera eastern Ukraine